I'm curious to hear your reaction to his
comments that are in the Sunday
Telegraph this morning talking about the
EU pursuing a similar goal that's a
Hitler and trying to create a super
state is that helpful to the out course
event well I don't think he was saying
that people who favor the European Union
were comparable to Nazis he was simply
saying that historically from the Romans
Charlemagne Napoleon there have been all
sorts of attempts to dominate Europe and
these have all floundered because Europe
is not naturally one entity so is it
helpful to say it I I don't actually
think what he said as it was said was so
outrageous I think the headline is
misleading
would you rather he hadn't said it
though I myself referred not so long ago
but was very careful to say I am NOT
comparing people who support Europe to
Nazis but it actually is a fact that
where fascist theorists who believed
very strongly in a united Europe let's
let's talk about the economy shall we
because as we were saying this week
we've had warnings from the Bank of
England and the International Monetary
Fund about the risks of leaving the EU
they governed the Bank of England talked
about a possible technical recession
Christine Lagarde from the IMF said that
the the prospects range from being
pretty bad very very bad has the the
leave can't lost the economic argument
do you think no I don't think it's lost
the argument
these are governmental institutions
which are putting their viewpoint
they're all very closely connected they
know each other well they work with with
each other even though the reports are
written by very similar people but you
know against them there are many private
sector economists who take a different
view working for private sector
institutions there are many
entrepreneurs who take a very different
view and there are a lot of professional
private investors well-known names in
the city who say Britain could prosper
perfectly well outside the EU you know I
think what we forget is that there are a
very large number of countries who are
not members of the EU but who export and
trade to the EU this idea that was put
around that some
Europe is a fortress with great high
walls and that you have to be in there
and part of the rules in order to trade
I'm afraid that just is not true
what colony today is saying that leave
campaigners are in denial about the
economic impact well I'm afraid I think
he's in denial himself about the
importance of trade agreements I think
they're vastly being overstated trade
goes where trade will go it goes where
people have a good product and where
there is a purchaser look at the United
States the United States literally a
much bigger economy than Britain but
thousands of miles away actually exports
more to the EU than we do now you can
say it's a bigger economy but there's
absolutely no say in the rules and yet
it manages to trade and when people say
an alternative has not been specified to
being in the EU the alternative is not
being in the EU and do defend Mark
Carney rather has defended his own
intervention he says it's entirely the
legitimate he said it would be
irresponsible not to tell people about
risks that if they believed but they
were there do you think that he was
right to speak out as he did I don't
think he was right to give a press
conference in the terms he did he
obviously had the monetary policy
committee meeting and they presented
their short-term report about the trend
of inflation and it is fair enough to
refer to it there but to go out and make
yet another intervention don't forget
we've had several of these from Mark
Carney and talking about a recession how
can he possibly know whether there would
be a recession or not I mean I didn't
believe there's any reason to think
forecasts aren't they yes but forecasts
are frequently wrong and I may point out
in particular
forecasts hardly ever foresee recessions
forecasts generally just extrapolate the
present into the into the future and you
know when people talk about a shock a
shock by definition is something unknown
and unexpected this whole EU referendum
campaign has caused great divides within
the Conservative Party hasn't it I mean
your former colleague John Major is
intervened this week and he's got some
firm words for conservatives in the
league can Michael Gove Boris Johnson
end up on Smithee he's talked about some
of their claim
not bearing scrutiny warned about the
tone of some of the rhetoric in the
campaign more broadly do you agree with
him no of course I don't agree and he's
right only in one point I think he's
right to say immigration should be
handled as a sensitive issue and I think
it will be and I think it has been
handled as a sensitive issue there I
think there's a bit of an attempt on
some people's part to try to shut down
any debate whatever on open borders and
immigration is a legitimate subject for
discussion in this referendum can the
party survive this kind of infighting
yes I think it can I think we've got to
treat each other with respect we've got
to come together afterwards
I believe that that that can be done it
requires the leadership to be generous
it requires us all to be generous can
David Cameron survive the vote if the
remain campaign loses should they become
and resign no I don't think you should
resign I think even if the vote is to
come out my own personal view is that
the Prime Minister having given the
people of this country an opportunity to
decide if they decide to leave I think
he should carry out the negotiation I
don't see by having off of the people
this just because he took one side I
didn't think you should resign reports
today suggest the next Tory leader
whenever that role becomes free will be
a brexit ear whatever the outcome of the
vote George Osborne appears to have a
lot of ground now to make up once it was
thought that perhaps he was the most
likely successor do you think that Boris
Johnson is the most likely next leader
dr. cotton look we've got a leader of
our party who is David Cameron we
respect him
he's going in my opinion he should
remain the leader come what may I'm not
going I'm afraid to get drawn in who I
think should be a leader when the Prime
Minister steps down as he said you will
step down before the next election but
do you think that it will be a brexit
heir who takes over
you can't tell you can't tell them long
way to go and what about George Osborne
there was a time as I say he was
considered the front I really I'm not
really don't want to discuss it's not a
decision now it's a decision that will
be made much later okay but you think
that David Cameron will
stay in the job to you until I mentioned
yes absolutely